cami wants a revolution she describes
the French state as a lousy system and
what she wants is no less than the end
of capitalism she's putting all her
faith in me dubu or rise up at night a
protest movement only weeks old that's
demanding greater social justice now me
too boo intends to join Frances unions
in calling a general strike duka me and
her fellow activists have a shot at
awakening the French revolutionary order
at the plaster looting or a couple of
protesters have made it onto the
theaters balcony but Cammy and others
want to get inside so they can hold a
general assembly they have to get past
the riot police surrounding the building
come e makes the first move at first the
Sundown appear to have the situation
under control but they can't maintain
the barrel
they resort to tear gas to drive the
protestors back
come he got a heavy dose but why was she
trying to break through the barrier
she's at no loss for an answer what is
it to fight against their system do you
guys feel awful I've never had it before
so every time I would you like some
water I hope it goes away it burns kami
is the 43 year olds known the gare many
of the activists have aliases often the
same one for many part of li the booze
messages that everyone's equal there are
no bosses and the goal is revolution we
could consciously butthole I want to
drive out the bosses we have to
confiscate the property and govern
ourselves not let capital but decide for
ourselves are we going to work work
shouldn't be all about profits but about
the common good people of Yakima so far
the revolutionary fervor has not spread
to the masses at large so meet abbulu is
looking to join forces with other
activists from the theaters balcony they
protest against the gutting of the state
unemployment insurance for artists come
he believes this week could be crucial
for the future of the movement will it
be revolutionary or just on the fringe
why I could I have only an open-ended
strike can pressure the government or
even bring it down normally people
strike for one day the government
doesn't care about that even if millions
of people collect in the streets to
reach the government of the bosses we
have to blockade the country's economy
he's young look bad economy to pay look
around and what if I told on the one st
she's calling for a general strike to do
that nita boo needs the union heads on
board people like I'll kill all of the
postal service we have to make ourselves
heard in the streets we have to regain
control over our lives
oh [ __ ] that movie sound aerosol suffix
what's happening here is interesting and
a little scary but to put some teeth
into the movement we need the students
the activists of nuit debout and the
workers to join forces if they do then
the government will be in a very tight
spot c720 a new google pneumonia primal
valley the strike is set to begin two
days later cami uses every minute she
has available to try to get people
mobilized on the subway floor she
scribbles a call to strike she serenades
her arch-nemesis the riot police and an
encore especially for our camera this
and con gets fuzzy kicks Minister Gibson
Ishmael aren't all kind of do's and
[ __ ] come he is a fan of the german
singer nina the devel teen women llegan
have I love Berlin woman thang
conditioned lassen fleegle until the end
of 2015 cami taught at a primary school
in Brittany then came the terror attacks
of November 13th and certain steps taken
by the government in their wake
Lita George Osborne was Attila the state
of emergency was the end of the last bit
of democracy we had friends of mine
fight against nuclear power were put on
a cross arrest at exactly the same time
as the climate change conference here in
Paris that way they wanted to prevent
all political activism echo guantánamo
Satipo oddity no I was like some
political sacrifices Francis left is
deeply disappointed with the socialist
government here on the plas de la
république the epicenter of new Dabu
that disappointment is heard and seen
everywhere cami felt so frustrated that
she quit her job she no longer wanted to
work for the state with two days to go
before the general strike if it happens
the committee discusses their plan of
action it's going out a steady job more
definite w/e meanwhile cami tries to
find out if the committee she's actually
looking for really is here I can't see
the banner of the general strike
committee Nita boo has been trying to
get people mobilized all across Paris
but several committees are still
underway on the plastid la publique the
organization can be confusing and some
people are saying the message needs to
be clearer even so the movements
achieved some results the government has
watered down its plan liberalisation of
the labour market where's good at school
the state is worried because we might
topple the system if the workers joined
forces they can oust the oligarchs and
the employers we have the know-how the
ability and the energy all they can do
is eat sleep and get rich at our expense
they have no productive abilities nope
it's also predicted ofits some might
disagree but one thing is certain when
Frances youth rises up the political
establishment gets worried as the
student revolts of 1968 showed these
activists see themselves as the
legitimate heirs of
students now it's just 24 hours till the
revolution or the strike begins if all
goes well kami and other activists have
stormed the comedie francaise the
theater had to cancel the evenings
performance the police give them free
reign kami finds her way to the balcony
above all the traffic below and sings us
another song
she's been sleeping on a couch of
friends of hers in Paris but not tonight
the occupiers settle in for a long night
with provisions delivered by rope new
Dabu lives up to its name let see this
more the next day on the Place de abajo
about 60,000 people have answered their
unions call to strike and have gathered
to protest the plan liberalisation of
the labour market this is the day cami
has been working for fueled by
adrenaline and getting very little sleep
her life as a primary school teacher is
far away she never wants to return to
that prison as she calls it I know
she'll mycotic now I feel truly in touch
with myself because now I'm living my
political values and ideas all the time
I'm no longer afraid of people the
migrants are otherwise I'm no longer
afraid at all that's very good you
propel the best fun but it's awesome
the demonstration itself is in the hands
of the unions in the middle of the
procession is gag you aren't leading his
postal workers kami drums people
together for the new rally to be held
later on the plastered on a fabric not
everyone here supports the movement yeah
we're not joining the official part of
the procession although were unionists
mm-hmm yes because the ones back there
don't want to know about the common
points in our struggle everyone for
themselves that's annoying another thing
that keeps many sympathizers at a
distance is the risk of rioters getting
violent suddenly clashes break out
several demonstrators and police
officers are injured
a few hours later kami is on the plaster
la république where night after night
new Dabu provides a forum for anyone
with anything to say Kimmy's tired she
has battle fatigue that's it music dog I
slept for three hours last night and not
at all this afternoon I don't know how
long I can keep going during the night I
wrote a song in a coed word comes
through that the strike will not be
continued for now even so come he seems
content Cindy Rico we're still at the
beginning the common cause that's taken
shape here in the demonstration and the
unrest is the starting signal for events
that could get even more radical of the
Basilica for now the revolution will
have to wait but there are social issues
and more than enough dissatisfaction
with the government kami already has
been radicalized and a certain others
will join in her struggle